today we're talking about the data cloud
summit google chronicle vm end to end
and startup guides i'm anew and welcome
to this week in cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news
organizations across all industries have
gravitated to google's tools for
building data clouds because of our
speed scale security and our
long-standing leadership in ai
if anyone has seen firsthand how data
can transform businesses and industries
it's our partners and customers and next
month you can too
get the perspective and insight you need
to turn your organization into a data
powerhouse at the data cloud summit on
april 6th register today
we are thrilled to announce the public
preview of context aware detections in
google chronicle
with this release we are creating
efficiencies in every step of a
customer's detection and response
journey starting by making alerts more
functionally enabled check out the blog
for more details
we publish another episode of vm end to
end which is a series of curated
conversations between a vm skeptic and a
vm enthusiast
every episode join brian carter and a
special guest as they explore why vms
are some of google's most trusted and
reliable offerings see how virtual
machines benefit companies operating at
scale in the cloud
check out the episode and transcript in
the blog
at google cloud
we want to provide you with the access
to all the tools you need to grow your
business the google cloud technical
guides for startups leverages
industry-leading solutions with how-to
video guides and resource handbooks
curated just for startups the
multi-series contains three chapters
start build and grow to match your
startup's stage of growth
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet at us we'll see
you in the cloud
you